[Music]
kill it
if you have to
[Music]
you're no stranger to big premieres but
how does this one feel for you crazy
amazing I mean it's amazing it's it's
the premiere where everyone feels
exactly the same we cannot wait we're so
excited
who your family is most excited that
you're part of Star Wars my dog is a
huge Chewbacca but my parents are pretty
excited but my kids are all here and
everyone is freaking out young like you
used to be like we used to be last
weekend we can talk about it but now
it's official big little I season 2 it
has been officially announced how
excited are you where do you think
Granada is gonna be at for an excuse
maybe in space but I don't know they may
have other ideas for her but I we just
go no David Kelly is mining his
brilliant brilliant brain and we'll see
what what he comes up with we're very
excited and and selfishly we just love
all working together and having an
excuse to actually go to work and work
with other women which we know has been
incredibly rare but we're all working on
that so very excited Globes noms are of
course Monday I mean you won the Emmy so
if your name is called how will you
celebrate how excited will you be we
will probably be just about attending
our
European Star Wars premiere so I will
continue the celebration with people I
get to love love knowing and working
with and I'll be with Luke Skywalker I
mean come on
[Music]
you
[Music]